good morning John
doing something
a little different today it's officially
countdown time
to project for us I set this video to
Premiere so theoretically there are a
bunch of people watching all at once
right now and they're all in the chat
together just chanting butt farting butt
Fartman butt Fartman over and over again
trying to summon him we'll see if that
works if you don't know who butt Fartman
is or beanie sandverbs or crank green or
Dave the fish or Glenn of the Glenn and
Dale of the Dale don't worry that's okay
they're all mascots of former projects
for awesome not this one what's gonna be
the mascot of this project for awesome
no one knows you don't know until you
start and then immediately I turn into a
crab for some reason and this happens
which is great no one doesn't like this
I didn't even realize we were making
mascots for the project for awesome
until last year after we had had like
over a dozen of them and I don't
remember the origin stories they all
have origin stories if you're gonna read
any of them you should read butt
fartman's
[Music]
excellent well done everyone you can
stop chanting now you successfully
summoned him now in the chat or in
comments if you're late you could just
type in the best parts of the project
for awesome according to you now you'd
think that a 48-hour live stream
dedicated to fixing the unfixable
problems of humanity and Earth would not
be so goofy this is actually something
I've noticed quite a bit if you sort of
know about the problems and you look at
the problems and you say oh that's
problem is problem that is somber it's
not fun but in the moments when I see
people actually working on hard problems
ideally together in community with
others the recognition of the magnitude
of the problem is still there that
didn't go away but also it just becomes
human community and human Community is
all of the things that humans always are
whether that is silly or goofy or sad or
serious or depressed or anxious or
joyful or whatever it's not joyful in
spite of the fact that it's directly
interfacing with you know some of the
greatest challenges that Humanity has to
face it's joyful because it isn't like
glancing at those things and then being
ashamed that they exist it's just
accepting that they are and that nothing
can ever be perfect but we can work hard
and when we work together we can magnify
our impact which this year is already
building off of over seven hundred
thousand dollars in matching grants so
if we can raise seven hundred thousand
dollars during the project for awesome
all of those initial dollars will be
matched and we will be at 1.4 million
dollars so recognizing the flaws in our
world and then witnessing our combined
impact yeah it's gonna be a little bit
joyful and then you add in the sleep
deprivation and you know you get what
you get so during the first half of the
project for awesome we will again be
raising money for Partners in Health and
save the children these are two
organizations that work to make life
better for some of the people who have
the very least on our planet and they
both do it in ways that build strong
foundations for those communities the
idea being that those people want to
work hard for themselves and their
families and their communities they want
to help each other out there are things
that weigh on those communities lack of
Access to Health Care and education not
having enough food or clean water we
know from evidence from experience that
if you give people the resources and a
strong foundation on which to build they
will build during the second half of the
project for awesome the money will go to
registered non-profits that are voted on
by this community so we divide that up
and we split it amongst 20 to 30
non-profits depending on how much we
rate people all over have made videos
talking about the great work that
non-profits that they know about do
those videos were submitted to project
for awesome.com we'll watch some of them
during the live stream but you can also
just watch them on the website now and
if you like the pitch you could vote on
the Charities at project for awesome.com
donate you will find a little rewards
button you'll click on that and there'll
be a lot of rewards you can scroll and
scroll and find all the different things
that are available and they're very good
there's so much and we will talk about
all of it at project for awesome.com
live which is where you should go the
moment this video ends which is right
now John I'll see you there